on a l'impression qu'on est plus rien
quoi on passe du mec number one
superstar à je sortais comme une merde
quoi
on passe maintenant à notre terrien du
samedi 20h
[Musique]
Vincent ferry rebonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes né le 2 novembre 1972 à Épinal dans
les Vosges père inséminateur mère femme
au foyer tout à fait adolescence vous
découvrez le scooter
et vous ne rêvez que d'une chose passez
votre permis moto un vrai rêve quoi un
rêve de gosse un rêve de gosse vous avez
15 ans quand votre père meurt dans un
accident de la route mais votre mère
prend le rôle de chef de famille et
malgré le choc les trois enfants s'en
sortent pas mal on est vraiment une
famille unie une famille très soudée
mais on s'en sort on serre les coudes et
on avance
à 18 ans votre bac scientifique en poche
vous décrochez votre fameux permis moto
et vous achetez une bécane immédiatement
j'ai eu mon permis moto avant le permis
voiture voilà c'est quoi la bécane 600
diesel magnifique alors après un BTS de
Commerce alimentaire vous faites un
stage en entreprise pour valider votre
diplôme et la société s'appelle claire
de Lorraine alors c'est une société qui
fait de la gastronomie du terroir il y a
cinq employés et un patron dites-vous
remarquable à l'ancienne c'est une bonne
ambiance on s'entend tous très bien
c'est un patron un peu paternaliste et
puis un jour ce patron vous appelle dans
son bureau et vous annonce qu'il veut
vous vendre sa boîte incroyable j'y
croyais pas j'étais stagiaire il me dit
je veux vendre l'entreprise et moi je
t'aime bien alors c'est à toi que je
veux la vendre parce que vous avez 22
ans vous avez jamais rien dirigé non
c'est Impens j'ai jamais eu de contrat
de travail je suis stagiaire voilà un
truc de fou et vous acceptez et
j'accepte bien évidemment alors le
problème c'est comment obtenir un
financement quand on a rien au vendez
tout la fameuse moto voilà l'appareil
photo décédé tout des fringues tout ce
qu'il faut pour récupérer l'argent et
alors le banquier vous dit j'ai le droit
de miser sur un cheval tous les ans
cette année ça sera toi coup de balle
incroyable alors vous n'avez pas 24 ans
lorsque vous prenez les reines donc de
Clair de Lorraine la première année
c'est une catastrophe perte 300000 euros
300000 balles à 24 ans c'est terrible
j'ai calculé que j'en avais jusqu'à
l'âge de 50 ans à rembourser et c'était
terrible quoi c'était tout était foutu
pour moi
et puis à partir de l'année suivante le
chiffre d'affaires grimpe devint 40% par
an là vous épousez Sophie votre amour
d'enfance et puis bon c'est la bonne vie
quoi vous avez un peu de thunes on vous
partez en vacances à Tahiti à l'île
Maurice en bossant comme un malade on
profite un peu tout va bien à vous
retrouver un autre amour de jeunesse
c'est la moto ça fait l'enduro l'idée
c'est d'aller de s'oxygéner en même
temps en se faisant plaisir en tirant un
peu sur la poignée de gaz en 2008 vous
avez 36 ans donc 50 salariés 800.000
euros de chiffre d'affaires et vous
multipliez le chiffre d'affaires par 10
tout à fait en fait on est à 800.000
euros quand je rachète et en 2008 je
suis à 8 millions incroyable un truc de
dingue en fait en se battant
vous faites un enfant avec Sophie vous
êtes au top quoi on est heureux la vie
est belle tout va bien et là le 29 mars
2008 vous rentrez les États-Unis le
temps plein de jet lag pas très en forme
vous roulez en moto dans dans le bois
pas vite 15 km/h voilà rien trou
tombé dans le trou et la moto vous tombe
dessus en fait j'ai peur l'erreur il
faut pas faire au lieu d'accélérer voilà
j'ai freiné et j'ai freiné trop fort je
suis passé par au dessus de la moto elle
me retombe cervicale 3 cervicalcat
heureusement que c'est pas la cervicale
1 sinon c'était le coup du lapin vous
étiez mort mort immédiate et là vous
êtes à plat ventre le visage dans la
boue
et vous réalisez très rapidement que
vous êtes paralysé j'ai tout de suite
compris j'ai dit à mon copain appelle un
hélico fait quelque chose une ambulance
vite je suis paralysée j'ai tout de
suite compris
à l'hôpital la neurochirurgienne vous
confirme effectivement le diagnostic de
tétraplégie et on vous dit que vous ne
marcherez plus jamais et vous n'aurez
plus jamais l'usage de vos bras et de
vos mains exactement
en fait à ce moment là je lui dis mais
c'est pas possible c'est une histoire de
fou on est en colère on dit mais c'est
pas vrai arrêtez il y a bien eu une
personne dans votre carrière qui a
réussi à marcher il y avait quelque
chose elle me regarde elle me dit il y
en a eu un en 20 ans
et là je me dis et je lui dis je serai
le deuxième
alors évidemment votre première pensée
là c'est le suicide ouais complètement
mais ce qui est catastrophique et ce qui
est complètement horrible c'est qu'on
peut même pas suicider c'est impossible
on peut pas prendre de cachet on peut
pas se prendre on peut pas se tirer une
balle dans la tête on peut rien faire on
peut que hurler et encore alors là quand
votre épouse Sophie s'approche de vous
vous pleurez et vous réalisez que vous
ne pouvez même pas vous essuyer le
visage exactement ça me procure des
démangeaisons terribles le nez cool je
ne peux absolument pas m'essuyer le
visage c'est les gens on est on est
tributaire de tout de tout le monde
alors vous lui dites je suis
tétraplégique j'ai tout bousillé j'ai
foutu ma vie en l'air j'ai fait une
connerie sauf toi à part je vais pas
bousiller ta vie également je veux dire
c'est déjà l'abnégation
mais Sophie elle elle me dit il est hors
de question que je te laisse on va se
relever tous les deux elle vous dit
exactement et là c'est des phrases
fortes c'est des moments forts qui
arrivent dans très rarement dans une vie
et ça c'est des moments extraordinaires
qui suivent vous découvrez l'enfer
d'être enfermé dans un corps inerte vous
dites on imagine pas à quel point c'est
dur de ne pas pouvoir se gratter c'est
terrible plus les mouches et les
moustiques commencent à arriver c'est
une liste d'atterrissage parfaite un
visage on peut pas bouger on peut rien
faire à part souffler un peu d'air c'est
une horreur une cinq six mouches sont
capables de vous faire péter un plomb là
dessus tout le monde vous conseille de
vendre la boîte et vous dites NON je
serai patron
était stratégique voilà c'est une
décision qu'on a pris également avec
Sophie et la famille en se disant un
moment donné très rapidement on a
compris on a dit voilà on va continuer
l'entreprise ça sera ton centre de
rééducation ton médicament à toi et vous
avez une pensée aussi pour les 50
employés tout à fait il y a 50 familles
quand même qui vivent entre guillemets
grâce à vous je me dis je peux pas les
lâcher je peux pas les laisser qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont devenir
à cause d'une connerie je peux pas aller
lâcher là on voit que vous êtes aux
antipodes des patrons voyous vraiment à
confondre c'est pas confondre
et là et là vous demandez à Sophie de
venir à l'hôpital avec un caméscope et
vous enregistrez un message
vous fait l'entendre j'ai le moral j'ai
la pêche vous en faites pas
je j'aimerais vraiment bien être avec
vous ça me ferait vraiment plaisir c'est
vraiment je regrette vraiment j'ai
beaucoup pensé à vous lors de cette
réunion bien écoutez passez une
excellente réunion et changez bien entre
vous que ce soit le plus constructif
possible puis je vous dis à très bientôt
allez au revoir
en fait c'est un effet incroyable ils se
disent bon ben lui il veut se battre et
ben on va se battre avec lui et là tout
le monde s'organise bosse comme des
malades c'est incroyable il y a un effet
qui se passe quelque chose imagine de
l'être humain alors voilà la rééducation
c'est quand même très très dur un jour
vous craquez votre secrétaire qui
s'appelle Véronique elle vous essuie les
yeux à un moment parce que vous pleurez
et vous lui dites voyez où j'en suis
quoi ma pauvre vous voyez ce que je suis
devenu on a l'impression qu'on est plus
rien quoi on passe du mec number one
superstar à je sortais comme une merde
quoi et elle vous dit c'est normal
monsieur ferry aujourd'hui vous avez
besoin de moi vous êtes un jour c'est
moi qui aurait besoin de VOUS ouais
c'était génial ça c'est quelque chose
magnifique vous vous ressaisissez très
vite alors au bout de 6 mois vous pouvez
manger tout seul j'ai réussi à retrouver
ma main c'est la fin de la becquet
extraordinaire la fin de la béquille de
se faire donner à manger tous les jours
et on a su le côté on vous il y en a
trop pas assez voilà enfin le bonheur je
retrouve le bonheur de pouvoir mettre
une fourchette à la bouche assez
extraordinaire et au bout d'un an vous
faites votre premier pas alors là les
médecins n'en reviennent pas c'est
incroyable la magie j'appelle ça mon
premier pas sur la Lune c'était
carrément extraordinaire c'était mon
objectif et j'avais reçu à atteindre cet
objectif là même si c'est que quelques
mètres c'est c'est super important pour
le mental alors on vous donne un
déambulateur et du marché
pleurer de joie ouais je pleure de toi
je suis heureux je commence à aller
mieux je prends je reprends de l'énergie
quoi je commence à avoir la banane et
tout ça vous amène à instaurer de
nouvelles méthodes de management
ça vous déléguer en fait je me suis
rendu compte qu'en délégué vont
délégance
super bien leur job et qu'en fait
j'étais pas du tout indispensable comme
beaucoup de patrons se prennent pour des
gens indispensables absolument et alors
la boîte continue à progresser de 20%
par an en 2012 Clair de Lorraine fait un
chiffre d'affaires de 11 millions
d'euros et vous permettez en plus
maintenant de former des valides aux
management je me suis retrouvé devant
200 300 personnes à Paris et je raconte
mon histoire et j'explique un petit peu
les techniques de management diriger
d'une façon différente et puis il
s'appelait énormément aux valides donc
c'est quelque chose vraiment incroyable
et là vous pensez maintenant à faire un
deuxième enfant ouais voilà c'est
vraiment notre rêve avec Sophie de
réussir à avoir un deuxième enfant ça
c'est ça serait vraiment le bonheur
[Applaudissements]
quelle histoire
il a de la chance d'avoir une femme
comme vous non oui et j'ai de la chance
aussi de la voir merci de votre
témoignage
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu